adam is with us in chicago illinois good
afternoon adam how can
ken and i help hey guys
uh i'm calling in i got kind of myself
into a financial situation
so i'm just about to finish med school
and before this i worked really hard i
got out of undergrad with no debt
okay there we go with med school i i
couldn't
you know blame that and right now i got
uh 420 993 in med school that
four hundred and twenty dollars you wish
four hundred twenty thousand
hundred thousand yeah i i wish you a
very
wow you graduated with your bachelor's
with no
no no debt now he's in 420 000 in med
school debt
okay how much do you make a year right
now adam he's not out yet
zero i'm i'm graduating right now
how much do you think you will make a
year
uh an intern depending on you know where
you're working exactly can be anywhere
between 52 to 60 k
oh my goodness and what's the eventual
goal
eventual destination the invent
eventual destination is interventional
radiology
and which is going to pay what range
very well
uh depending on you know where you work
and the type of practice you're in
anywhere between 350 to eight
cool okay so what's your question we've
only got about a minute and a half
okay so my question for you guys is i
know that the
public service loan forgiveness those
guys are not getting their loans
you know forgiven it's only like one
percent uh
i ran the numbers and with what i'm
taking home
if i'm able to you know tutor
a little bit throughout the week i can
augment that enough to where i'll
barely be able to make the payments to
pay
you know this off theoretically in 10
years with the
with the graduated plan would you guys
suggest that over you know making the
bare minimum
uh loan payments that i see you know so
many of my
colleagues make and then you know it's
20 years post med school and they're
still you know paying this thing off
adam how old are you man i'm 30. all
right cool great here's the thing adam
you're going to be 30 for the rest of
and for the next 10 15 years you're
going to work
like you're 30 you're going to live like
you're 30 for the next 10 years you
do not have time for luxury you do not
have time
for fun you're in 420
000 worth of debt right now yes you're
gonna work your behind
off you're gonna make extra payments if
your girlfriend comes up to you and says
hey baby can we go out to eat you're
gonna tell her no we can have peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches
at the house you're not getting a nice
car you're gonna get an
ugly car you're gonna get a car that you
could pay for cash i'm sorry
but that's what you gotta do